it is true that we now see this
consciousness for which being means what
is its own revert to the standpoint of
meaning and perceiving but not in the
sense that it is certain of what is
merely an other previously its
perception and experience of various
aspects of the thing were something that
only happened to consciousness but here
consciousness makes its own observations
and experiments meaning and perceiving
which previously were superseded for us
are now superseded by and for
consciousness itself reason sets to work
to know the truth to find in the form of
a notion that which for meaning and
perceiving is a thing that is it seeks
to possess and thing hood the
consciousness only of itself reason now
has therefore a universal interest in
the world because it is certain of its
presence in the world or that the world
present it is rational it seeks its
other knowing that therein it possesses
nothing else but itself it seeks only
its own infinitude
now moving into paragraph 240 we're
beginning a subsection of this massive
section of the work reason and we're
going into observing reason but old
Optima for note in the German again so
we're going to see in the next three
paragraphs after this and then this
paragraph as well Hegel's setting the
stage for what a lot of other paragraphs
to follow is going to deal with and so
what we've got to use a little bit of
outlining but also you know sort of
preliminary work yeah in this paragraph
he's talking in particular about
previous stages that we've already gone
through and the activities that are
associated with them so meaning Mayan
was associated with the sense certainty
portion that you know is the very first
thing that we tried to to engage in why
because we thought that that was the
most concrete and it turns out that
perceiving in that way turns out to be
the most abstract then we moved on to
perceiving as such learning perceiving
the thing and its properties right and
notice what he doesn't have here he
doesn't have the force in the
understanding or any sort of reference
to that could we read that in it we
almost have to in part because Hegel is
going to be talking here about world and
world as it exists for reason and what
he wants to say is that we've got an
activity that formerly had a particular
meaning or significance to it and it's
been transformed now and likewise the
object of that has been transformed as
well the operations are going to be
somewhat different so let's let's go
through and see what he's he's actually
saying here he says that we see now that
this consciousness for which beating
means what is its own right reason
thinks and everything in a certain way
is
it's owned it it falls within the scope
of Reason revert to the standpoint of
meaning and perceiving but not in the
sense that it is certain of what is
merely and other we've seen this dynamic
you know the the consciousness has to
exist in relation to and other the other
is sometimes in other consciousness
sometimes it's the other thing sometimes
it's the other with the end right and so
you know what it was being encompassed
here as other he says previously it's
perception and experience of various
aspects of the thing or something that
only happened to consciousness so in a
certain way consciousness wasn't aware
of its own dynamism its own activity it
sees the thing as you might say teaching
it certain lessons opening itself up to
it as it engages in phenomenology
writing out what actually is out there
what does a period and so it appears to
be going this way reason on the other
hand is much more active so he goes on
and he says here consciousness makes its
own observations and experiments so
instead of merely perceiving it directs
itself to perceive and some of merely
having experiences it deliberately goes
about trying to have experiments which
is like experience right yeah he goes on
and he says meaning and perceiving which
previously were superseded for us who
preceded you know because they were
early dialectics now bars now superseded
by afore consciousness itself now
remember what happens when we have a
super session and okay it's not that we
just completely leave it behind
instead we transform it in the process
into something that means more that that
has a greater significance we leave
would be having a lot of dentists that's
for sure but we try to grasp the
necessity of what was going on and so
meaning and perceiving are taken into
might say reason all right so he goes up
and he says reason sets to work to know
the truth reason aims at finding the
truth finding the truth in the form of a
notion no longer just a thing but a
bigger if a concept a notion something
that reason itself can grasp as such he
says it seeks to find that the truth is
in the form of a notion that much for
meaning and perceiving is just a thing
so the object for consciousness is being
transformed as well it's not to say that
the things don't exist but we have
notions of things we we grasp things
eating our consciousness and thereby
sort of unpack what the thing really is
so he says it seeks to possess in thing
who it the consciousness only of itself
so what's going on here is you might say
a reordering or a prioritization of self
over other the self of consciousness the
self that is trying to find out itself
through reason so he goes now he says
reason now he has therefore a universal
interest in the world it is extending
itself out into the world of things why
because it is certain of its presence in
the world where that the world present
to it is rational and here we get to a
very famous dictum of Hegel you know the
real is rational the rationale is real
we should always probably at this point
of the dialectic insert a not yet isn't
ever because we're not doing like Hegel
said this empty idealism which merely
asserts an identity reason with whatever
it is that reason is studying that has
to be worked out but that realization
itself is a sort of conquest that is
to allow us to move on so he says it
seeks its other knowing that they're in
a possesses nothing else than itself so
other is no longer truly other to it the
other is not something radically fourth
and so what is it doing he says it seeks
only its own infinitude now why do i
infinitive this entire play of you know
the dialectic is in a certain sense
infinite and remember facts are just a
few discussions before where Hegel was
talking about the sensuous infinite this
is not just the sensuous in that we're
trying to grasp what is really there in
terms of its intelligibility
well at first it is only dimly aware of
its presence in the actual world there
only knows quite simply that this world
is its own it strides forward in this
belief to a general appropriation of its
own assured possessions and plants the
symbol of its sovereignty on every
height and in every depth but this
superficial it is mine is not its
ultimate interest the joy of this
general appropriation finds still in its
possession the alien other which
abstract reason does not contain within
itself reason is dimly aware of itself
as a profounder essence than the pure
eye is and must demand that difference
that being in its manifold variety
become its very own that it be holds
itself as the actual world and find
itself present as an outer shape and
thing but even if reason digs into the
very entrails of things and opens up
every vein in them so that it may gush
forth to meet itself it will not attain
this joy it must have completed itself
inwardly before it can experience the
consummation of itself
now in paragraph 241 Hindle is counter
posing reason to the world and he's
telling us that reason at this stage
particularly in the form of what he's
calling abstract reason doesn't fully
grasp it's on relation to the world that
it's attempting to how should we put it
to penetrate to open up to unfold now
reason does have the sense that the
world is rational that the things within
it that reason can go on to appropriate
are there for a reason at least in a
potential sense that is what is rational
what is intelligible in them what is
available in the form of the notion is
something weeding there for a reason to
uncover so he goes on they says when I'm
at first it's only dimly aware of its
presence in the actual world it sees the
world is something apart from itself
right reasons presence let's put the
presents over here yeah that's something
that it still has to make evident to
itself and that's not going to happen
right away so he goes on he says it only
knows quite simply this world is its own
it strides forward in this belief to a
general appropriation right on its own
assured possessions the things of the
world even so far as they can be
understood and also in a practical sense
insofar as they can be judged so far as
they can be prioritized selected for and
against rearranged into different ways
they were therefore for a reason so the
reason that we're talking about here is
there's something you know that that's
quite attempting to identify with you
know the beginning of modernity but we
could think about this also extending
backwards into
evil at ancient times as well so he goes
on he says it plants the symbol of its
sovereignty it's a nice phrase right
there symbol of its side remedy on every
fight and in every depth now of course
that's not super easy it's correct
present on a blackboard or we just have
you know two dimensions but here's the
heights and here's the debt whatever it
is in the world that reason can
appropriate and and enter into it will
do so whether it's something you know
high like the heavens or whether it's
the you know the infinitesimal you know
bits of things or as we're going to see
it in later paragraphs in later sections
the human mind itself and reason it's
awful so he goes on he says this
superficial it is mine alright this
appropriation saying this is mine this
is mine this is mine these it is not its
ultimate interest what is reason really
striving for here we get something like
you month what you might call as other
later philosophers have a will to truth
right what is it that reason is really
striving for what is reason truly
desirable Hegel tells us right here it's
it's desiring a joy the joy of this
general appropriation fine still in its
possession the alien other which
abstract reason does not contain within
itself so long as there remains alterity
reason and a certain sense can't be
entirely happy because it can't be
entirely what it is now on the other
hand once alterity has been vanished or
reduced everything has been homogenized
reason can't really be happy either
because it needs what the other brings
to so what we see here in handle this is
something really you know unique
to Hegel's perspective it has this
realization that you can't get away from
the other even when making everything
into the self he says reason is dimly
aware of itself is a profounder essence
then the pure is that's why I put the
contrast here right so we've been
dealing with the pure eye up until this
my consciousness consciousness and you
know some abstract sense and reason
becomes aware that it contains more than
the pure eye and not just an empirical
shell we might say we're instantiation
that the pure I would give to a person
writing on the the phenomenal as opposed
to the new middle of milania's patch in
categories reason contains alterity and
difference within itself that as Hegel
is going to tell us here so he goes on
he says it must have made that
difference that being in its manifold
variety become its own so all of the
difference here has to become something
for a reason that also goes back into
reason itself and it's a mistake in a
certain sense to represent things in
this way as if as if reason is actually
outside of the world because the world
encompasses the conscious being does it
not right but on the other hand
consciousness encompasses the world as
well and so the all tyranny involved
here in something for reason that it
must make sense out he goes on and he
says it what does it want it must behold
itself as the actual world and find
itself present as an outer shape and
thing so to find itself its own
rationality present in the world as
thing right deep in German and what
you're seeing here is a shape is as a
Gestalt as you know a shape of
consciousness so there's this dynamic
interplay between
and consciousness or world and and
reason going on and he says look even if
reason digs into the very entrails of
things opens up every vein in them so it
may gush forth to mean itself right
reason recognizes the rationale here and
rationale here right now here keeps on
doing this devices processes by which it
can keep on doing this he says it will
not attain this joy it must have
completed itself inwardly before it can
experience the consummation itself so
what it is that reason is you might say
motivated by as desire can't be realized
until we work our way through the
dialectical progressions
consciousness observes that is reason
wants to find and to have itself as
existent object as an object that is
actually in sensuously present the
consciousness that observes in this way
means and indeed says that it wants to
learn not about itself but on the
contrary about the essence of things qua
things that this consciousness means and
says this is implied in the fact that it
is reason but reason as such is not is
not as yet object for this consciousness
if it knew that reason is equally the
essence of things and of consciousness
itself and that it is only in
consciousness that reason can be present
in its own proper shape it would go down
into the depths of its own being and
seek reason they are rather than in
things if it did find it there it would
be directed to the actual world outside
again in order to behold there in reason
sensuous expression but at the same time
to take it essentially as notion reason
as it immediately comes before us as the
certainty of consciousness that it is
all reality takes its reality in the
sense of the immediacy of being and
similarly the unity of the eye with the
subjective being in the sense of an
immediate unity in which it is not yet
divided and reunited with the moments of
being in the eye or which has not yet
discerned them reason therefore in its
observational activity approaches things
in the belief that it truly apprehends
them is sensuous things opposite to the
eye but what it actually does
contradicts this belief for it
apprehends them intellectually it
transforms their sensuous being into
notions that is into just that kind of
being which is at the same time I tense
transforms thought into the form of
being or being into the form of thought
it maintains in fact that it is only as
notions that things have truth
consciousness in this observational
activity comes to know what things are
but we come to know what consciousness
itself is the outcome of its movement
will be that which consciousness is in
itself will become explicit for it
paragraph 242 is laying out a
predicament or a problematic of reason
then not only have already seen sketched
out and it's elaborating one more aspect
of it we could say and where we're going
to go from from here in a certain sense
it's very very optimistic because it's
saying well reason is mixed up at first
about just what it's doing and you know
what what is role in consciousness is
supposed to be but higgles showing us we
hadn't seen what reason could be
realizing itself to be and so he's
showing us the path ahead so he says you
know the consciousness observes reason
wants to find in him itself as an
existent object an object that is
actually an sensuously present and how
does it do that by turning to the world
that is objectively in sensuously
prescient to and inferring to find
itself within that world and it doesn't
just you know tabulating up a bunch of
different things perceiving the
particulars it tries to get to the
essence of them and we've seen this
happen not only you know perception and
the thing in its properties but but also
the force the understandings section in
the previous sections of
self-consciousness where it's attempting
to understand the social world all that
is is trying to get at this this essence
as he says he says it wants to learn not
about itself right consciousness
observes and says it wants to learn out
about itself but on the contrary about
the essence of things and why does it do
that
because it thinks well that's real that
has being as opposed to just thought
over here thought is you know in a
certain sense you know the shadow of
being I want the real stuff over over on
this side so he goes on and he says it
wants to learn about the essence of
things quantum things that is
consciousness means and says this is
implied in the fact that it is reason so
this is something that is of the essence
of reason that it's seeking essence now
notice what we've done
this is going to be very important is
all of essence they denied on this side
of the picture no because we just said
that reason itself is in a certain way
you know an essence or it has an essence
or it is essential right there's
something to it dad that fits in there
and the question is well how is it going
to take stock of them at first it's not
going to at all as we see so he knows
already says reason as such has not yet
object for this consciousness and it'll
become object for the consciousness when
it becomes reflexive right when it
descends into what he's great a column
just a few sentences the depths of its
being and what is it going to find there
in the depths of its being first then we
gotta say well why would it even bother
to go into the depths of its being when
it's got this whole wide wonderful world
out here to explore that's a serious
question right so he says if a new
reason is equally the essence of things
and of consciousness itself than that it
is only unconsciousness that reason can
be present in its own proper shape very
important right reason can be present in
its own proper shape or its Gestalt
right and so on form is another way we
just think of us so reason can find
itself partly out here in the world of
things by grasping their essence whether
we understand this essence in terms of
universals in terms of you know dynamic
between things in terms of laws in terms
of world itself forces all of these
these sorts of things organ grasped
itself in terms of its own proper
substance its own proper home in a way
reason is both in and out of the world
this should remind you by the way the
force of the understanding and the
whirl discussion right when I say things
like that so you might want to go back
to the to that section and think about
it that's why these previous sections
were stuff the only reason that's any
reason why these previous sections were
so important because what they provided
us with once sublated gets taken up into
these further sections so he goes on and
he says you know reason can be present
in its own proper shape it would go down
to the depths of its own being and seek
reason there rather than in things
so if reason truly understood its own
nature well you know of course if it
truly understood its own nature wouldn't
have to go seeking it there within it I
know you have something like the Meno a
paradox happening there but insofar as
it is a good inkling of where to go it
is going to seek its own nature within
itself now what is it going to find
there is it going to find the you know
pure reflex emanate and the abstraction
of the pure I know it's not because what
makes it reason it is the very fact that
it is observing and connected with the
outside world of things which for it are
now being transformed as we saw in
previous paragraphs into notions
it has intelligent and it's
intellectually apprehending them as
Hegel says as notions it is you might
say squeezing the intelligibility out of
them and you know leaving the husks
behind and appropriating that to itself
very interesting and in some ways
aggressive process isn't it
so you notice underneath says reason as
it immediately comes before us is the
certainty as a certainty of
consciousness that it is all reality
takes its reality in the sense of the
immediacy of being and what does the
immediacy of being it means your being
is this world of things and their
essences if we get away from the medias
in which we're always supposed to do
right because everything's always
mediated forgetting out
and then you know we're going to proceed
to try to grasp what's happening here
reflexively so he goes I have the unity
of the I was the subjective being in the
sense of an immediate unity right the
pure I whenever you haven't counterpose
to the world we want to get away from
them we want to grasp these things in
their relation says reason in its
observational activity approaches things
in the belief that it truly apprehends
them a sensuous things opposite to the
eye right so it's it's it's seeing
itself as the eye it wants to go out
there and find what's out there for it
think of it like somebody playing you
know a video game whether it's a Forex
game or a first-person shooter or you
know massive multiplayer game they want
to explore the world and see how it
works and start thinking about how
things are connected with each other we
observe we learn we don't just want to
like look at ourselves and some people
might do a little bit of navel-gazing
because we provide ourselves with you
know stats and things like that but even
those are you know from a djeli any
perspective are just sort of you know
bigger husks right so you go without any
sense reason is approaching things in
the belief that it truly apprehends them
what it actually does contradicts this
belief why because it apprehends them
intellectually this is what it means to
grasp the essence to grasp them
intellectually to grasp them in their
notions this is what it finds in its own
depths of being a connection with the
world and the things of the world that
can perceive sensuously but also
apprehend on a higher level
intellectually it can make sense of them
it's not just an empty you know
circularity it's it's a well-stocked you
know let's use de currents term you know
he uses the term thesaurus actually
which means something like stewart house
or a treasure house of ideas
that's what reason finds within
so he says it transforms through
centuries being into notions into just
the kind of being which is at the same
time I hens transforms thoughts into the
form of being or being into the form
thoughts so before we have an opposition
between thought over here and being over
here and thought was I love being and so
in a certain sense thought didn't want
to think about itself because we would
rather be over here with being where
things are happening and it's much more
exciting but really what's been going on
the entire time Justin word force a lot
to think being it has to transform being
into thought and what its grasping are
not the things you know as bare sensuous
particulars out here but what it can
make of them what would you know it can
transform limited because I'm me says
it's only as notions that things have
truth truth doesn't lie on this side
except insofar as reason has entered
into it it's a very important point
reason can have certainty about these
things but they don't have truth in
themselves truth comes when reason is on
the scene
connecting itself up with it them so he
goes nobody can clue as he says
consciousness and this observational
activity comes to know what things are
but we come to know what consciousness
itself is now is consciousness out of
the picture no it's consciousness that
is coming to know what consciousness is
and we've seen this the schema many
times already in discussing Hegel's
dialectics any time that you have
consciousness on the the other of the
outside it's also consciousness of self
that has implicitly involved and can be
made explicit so he says the outcome of
the movement of its movement will be
what consciousness is in itself will
become explicit for it that is the goal
that is how we're going to get
out of this this you know original
predicament or problematic hey like I
said let's just turn it out the path
that we're going to have to traverse in
this section observing reason
this action of reason in its
observational role we have to consider
in the moments of its movement how it
looks upon nature and spirit and lastly
upon the relationship of both in the
form of sensuous being and how it seeks
itself as actuality in the form of
immediate being
taking brains this subsection to close
in paragraph 2 43 which is very short
and in the Miller translation is
slightly misleading so I've got things
here on the board arranged in a way that
perhaps gives you a better sense of
where we're going
he says that this action of reason in
its observational role we have to
consider in here we find that right so
what are we doing the path ahead
involves reason as it engages in the
action of observation and we are
ourselves observing reason or we are
being conscious of it as we're doing so
because we're doing a phenomenology
right
we're following out the developments of
reason and Hegel does have in mind here
are things that are identifiable with
historical or at least historically
existing shapes of consciousness right
not necessarily that the grand dynamism
of history and every single point but
quite often you know recurring motifs
right you know so what does that what
does that mean to the consistent so he's
going to talk about the moments of its
movements and Hegel loves those terms
right the moments are the things that
are being distinguished from each other
and that united with each other or
connected with each other are
transforming each other and there is a
dynamism or movement there what is that
dynamism what are we going to be
observing reason engaging well in part
nature right so this this observing
reason will be in part about observing
the world as it presents itself to us as
being you know something outside
something external something that the
human subject is not directly
interfering with or or you know
influencing how we're going to put it
very quickly of course as we move into
other sections you know when we see I'm
talking about for example observation of
self-consciousness in relation to extra
actuality or observation of
self-consciousness in relation to its
immediate actuality we are already
talking about the human being
being understood is you might say a
natural thing but this is going to lead
us beyond to something that's not quite
so natural or at least its relation to
nature is not quite so immediate and
straightforward and then it's spirit got
it right we might want to contrast here
nature versus culture but for Hegel it
goes beyond merely that you know the
idea of nature versus cultures there's
like a nature and then there's human
beings and they superimpose culture on
it and in some way you know incorporate
nature into the culture as its basis and
and provide an interpretation of nature
but Haiti will think that that spirit
does more than that
that spirit is in a certain way
grounding nature or these permeating
nature and so we're going to see this
discussed in these other later sections
what is what he's summarizing here is
not merely what we're going to see in
observing reason but also in the other
two subsections actualization of
rational self-consciousness through its
own activity which is going to include
things like pleasure a necessity and
individuality which shapes itself to be
real in and for itself so we're looking
at and you know the development of
nature or the you know presentation of
nature as we're able to break it up and
make sense of it get to its essence
spirits you know the distinctively human
aspects and then the relation of both to
each other which turns out to be more
fundamental in many ways the answer and
then we're going to look at how you know
reason seeks itself as an actuality like
it says how it seeks itself as an
actuality in the form of immediate being
which by the way is a rather kick sonic
Enterprise because it's never going to
have us all truly in the form of
but the very fact of seeking itself that
way is going to propel it forward it's
going to learn in its failures and in
its mistakes so Hagel has charted out
where we're going now we are going to be
moving into the the you know minor
section which it turned out to be quite
long observing reason